relancer les négociations avec moscou
pour éviter une escalade des tensions
entre la russie et l'ukraine c'est
l'objectif des dirigeants de l'union
européenne réunis à bruxelles
aujourd'hui le dossier russo ukrainien
qui s'est également imposé hier lors de
la réunion entre les dirigeants des
vingt-sept et leurs homologues des pays
du partenariat oriental et pour en
parler on retrouve à moscou notre
correspondant antoine gayraud
ces derniers jours la présidente de la
commission européenne mais encore le
ministre français des affaires
étrangères ont eu des mots très forts
envers la russie en effet la menace de
conséquences stratégiques massives en
cas d'atteinte à l'intégralité du
territoire ukrainien la porte parole de
la diplomatie russe a répondu une
nouvelle fois à ces accusations en
disant que son pays n'avait nullement
l'intention
il s'agit d'une campagne lancée
délibérément de fausses informations de
désinformation qui vise à créer d'une
part une image de la russie en tant
qu'agresseur et d'autre part
probablement à créer des tensions
supplémentaires dans la région de la mer
noire de l'ukraine de la frontière russo
ukrainienne dans la situation dans le
sud est de l'ukraine tout cela
n'apportera pas d'éléments de stabilité
et de sécurité tant dans les relations
internationales en général que dans
l'agenda régional
bladier poutine a plusieurs fois pris la
parole ces derniers jours pour évoquer
le dossier ukrainien et pour justifier
la présence de troupes russes à sa
frontière à la suite de ces différentes
interventions maria sharapova a tenu a
résumé la position de la russie sur ce
sujet
sur la base de certaines données
ouvertes et secrètes les représentants
du gouvernement allemand ont établi que
l'armée russe était situé sur le
territoire de la russie eh bien je les
félicite pour cette découverte oui il ya
une armée russe sur le territoire de la
fédération de russie quand un état
dispose de ses forces armées qui se
trouvent sur son territoire il a le
droit de mener des exercices de
redéployer ses forces qui plus est de
mettre en oeuvre la réforme des forces
armées ou je ne sais pas d'effectuer des
manoeuvres sur son propre territoire
nous faisons cela sur notre territoire
nous en avons le droit
patiemment les autorités russes que ce
soit le kremlin ou le ministère des
affaires étrangères explique à qui veut
l'entendre que la russie n'a aucune
velléité offensive et qu'elle cherche
simplement assurer la sécurité de son
territoire et c'est d'ailleurs avec cet
objectif en tête que moscou cherche à
ouvrir au plus vite des négociations
avec l'alliance atlantique